[Music]
[Music]
take it away warning yeah
good morning Helsinki thanks for having
me I'm gonna introduce yon one of the
cofounders of this event let's bring up
the chair do you guys have the video
prompted so good morning everyone before
we go into our keynote we have a bet to
settle that we created a couple months
ago and there's some video footage for
context for this audience
I'm awfully excited about what I get to
do in a little bit do they have the
video because I'd love to play it yes we
have the video could you roll their
penal on the video so this is gonna be
all rise
this is Johanna and I in Sweden and I
was asking people how much it would cost
to shave their head and Yan said he all
he needed was a hundred dollars so this
is a babban one of my video guys and
he's now running around trying to find a
razor in theory in theory to come
all right all right thank you
Yanis so what I respect about yond
is that he's a man of his word we made a
bet to shave his head for a hundred
bucks
he said when you get to Helsinki we will
uh we will take care of it so I'm gonna
pull out my hundred dollars
all right well it's not done yet for you
put that on thank you it's real
hundred-dollar bill
not even a euro well all right I'm gonna
excuse myself and you can yeah I've
never shaved a man's head before so I
hope this doesn't hurt you
good all right I'm gonna I'm gonna do
the first cut then I'm gonna move you on
over and give the keynote because that's
what you're here for but are you ready
let's clap it up for this gentleman
[Applause]
hello dear Rach it's actually fun
[Applause]
[Music]
this is [ __ ] awesome all right that's
good let's clap it up for him he really
you look great
great good morning
so the format that we've set up here is
I'm gonna give a 20 or 30 minute kind of
20 or so minute and then we're gonna
open up for about 20-25 minutes of Q&A
and so the thing that I really wanted to
talk about this morning was a couple of
different pillars that I'm seeing in the
marketplace that I think will help the
individuals in this room and I think the
word that I want to focus on most of all
this morning is practicality I think
when I think about the the makeup of the
individuals in this room whether they
come from a corporate environment or in
a startup or an entrepreneur two years
into their business 20 years into their
business I think the thing that really
resonates with me is especially at this
point in the evolution of the Internet
which is really what we're all kind of
sitting here and talking about there's a
really interesting Delta of the people
in this audience in this market of
Helsinki and Europe the US mainland
China the people that are clearly
accelerating are the ones that
understand the practicality of the
moment not where blockchain is going not
what television commercials used to do
for them
but who's actually marketing and
executing in a May June 2018 world and
taking advantage of where all of our
collective attention is and what to do
with it based on their business
objectives today and within the short
term and so for me the thing that's most
interesting is that in a world where
things like AI and AR and the emerging
block chains that I think are gonna be
built in the next couple of years and in
a world of voice which I'm unbelievably
passionate about and really I do think
that
the apps built on top of Alexa and
Google home apple pod are no question
going to have the same impact on our
society the way that ways or Spotify er
Shopify or Instagram had as apps on top
of the iPhone in that whole world to me
that feels like 12 24 36 48 60 months
from where it starts making an impact to
me if I have any impact on this audience
today the places where I want to go on
are where I think you can have the
biggest return on what you're trying to
do be regardless of what you're doing
whether you're developing an incredibly
large project that you're working on
whether you're selling sneakers whether
it's t-shirts or your services whether
you're a SAS company a media company no
matter what anybody does here running
for mayor no matter what anybody does
here the currency is attention the
currency that we all strive for is
attention and then once you have the
attention the game that we all need to
play is the ability to create words in
written form audio video or pictures to
inspire an action that we're intrigued
by for me that plays out very simply
when I look at the landscape today this
is the remote control and the platform
of our attention and when you look at
the data of how much time is spent on
YouTube and Facebook and Twitter and
Instagram and LinkedIn on this device
social networks or content platforms
that we now call social networks
represent almost half the time humans
spend on a cell phone I think we can all
agree that the amount of time we spend
on a cell phone is staggering and
continues to grow for me if you are not
producing audio written words videos and
pictures for those seven to eight
platforms today on a daily basis
consistently you are on the beginning
process of completely relevance in our
society and for me not having a complete
religion around that is a grave grave
mistake the other thing that becomes
unbelievably interesting for me this
morning at this keynote is the fact that
in this market Helsinki Finland and the
Nordics as a whole the two platforms
that I obsessed the most over today for
scale Facebook and Instagram the ads the
influencer marketing market and the
organic reach are all dramatically more
interesting in this market than they are
in other parts of Europe
definitely than they are in the US and
Canada and other parts of South America
if I can really get you to a very simple
place this morning the only thing you
actually fundamentally have to
understand is that Facebook ads both in
Instagram and Facebook form in this
market are so under priced that even if
you are average at the creative that you
put behind those ads you will get
disproportionate return on your business
whether you're b2b or b2c to me that is
a moment that I haven't seen since early
Google when I think about my career when
I launched an e-commerce wine business
in 1996 I was able to build a business
that was doing three million dollars a
year on 10% gross profit so $300,000
before expenses a business of that size
with a $14,000 a year marketing budget
in year one I was able to build that
business from a three to a sixty million
dollar business in five years a hundred
percent on the back of email and Google
AdWords when I look back at that story I
have enormous amounts of regret because
I genuinely believe that that should
have been three to two hundred million
dollars the mistake I made in my youth
the mistake I made that many people made
was I just didn't understand how good of
a deal Google AdWords were from 2000 and
2004 they were so remarkably underpriced
that I wasn't able to quantify specially
since I had no prior experience that I
was buying beachfront property that I
was digging up gold at
enormous lilo prices that underlining
understanding in hindsight is what
drives me this morning to suffocate
anybody's excuses in this room
- why Facebook - why Instagram doesn't
work or for the people who actually
watch this how many people here have run
Facebook ads and it didn't force a work
as well as you wanted which I'm sure is
for a lot raise your hands
actually raise some hi please I want to
see this so I think this is what's super
important there's an enormous percentage
of people here who've already done what
I'm spitting as the thing you need to be
doing but I want to make sure that 20%
of this room that just raised her hand
understood that there are so many
variables that go into something not
being successful most of all the biggest
variable is you probably did not do a
good job executing the campaign at the
end of the day when you think about the
ROI of something the ROI of anything is
always far greater for the people that
are good at it versus bad at it the ROI
of a piano for me is zero the ROI of a
piano for Elton John is over a billion
dollars so to me the concern I have is
that we're sitting right now in this
prime era where everybody in this room
and I mean everybody
government employees down to
entrepreneurs selling a tie on the
internet all have unbelievable
whitespace in this medium and I believe
that there's a gross misunderstanding
and I I challenge and predict that
everybody in this room that doesn't run
a hefty amount of Facebook Ads Instagram
ads and Instagram influencer campaigns
during this next 24 to 36 months will
look back at this speech and this era
with the same regret that I have through
my body - what I did from 2001 to 2004
which is you may win and do quite well
but please don't misunderstand it you've
left an enormous opportunity on the
table
you know it's so funny in the US I've
been pontificating this for about three
or four years and by the way just for
those who are scoring at home the cost
of the CPM on Facebook has gone up
substantially in the last 24 to 36
months globally and definitely in the
u.s. yet still grossly less than it
deserves it's interesting I want imitate
this and big company see Wow let's clap
it up this is [ __ ] clean all right
thank you guys in the US I have the
biggest CEOs in the world arguing to me
that this platform doesn't sell their
product that Facebook's not ROI positive
meanwhile in the other side of their
mouths they're complaining to me that
it's bringing down the American
democracy and things of that nature I
mean you're talking about a platform
then it's so fundamentally powerful that
the CEO of the company had to present in
front of Congress over a two day period
on its impact on the psychology of the
end consumer this is not this is not a
platform that everybody here should be
under estimating I would argue including
me who is no question one of its biggest
cheerleaders everybody everybody at this
conference is under estimating it so
first and foremost very simply in a very
practical way taking a step back and
understanding what's happening for real
on Facebook for real in both its media
capabilities and it's a creative
capabilities is something I implore
everybody here to do as far as
practicality the other thing that I want
to really talk about is how remarkable
this era actually is in a in a macro we
are living through what is now a 2025
year invention in our society as much as
we underestimate Facebook I believe that
we underestimate the Internet as a whole
dramatically more everything is being
played out on top of this platform and
for me
for how many people here are
entrepreneurs or startups raise your
hands
amazing so for me one of the biggest
things that I want to talk about is the
ecosystem at this moment around this
platform meaning it's never been more
practical to actually make money in a
world where one more time hands DC you
know startups entrepreneurs in a world
where all of us over the last decade
have been pushed enormous propaganda
around raising money and me watching as
you know I made my first investment 2007
my first three investments were Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr and as you can
imagine that worked out tremendously
well for me but it's interesting to see
what's happened in the 11 years since I
invested in tumblr after it had tens of
millions of users in its be round at a
14 million dollar valuation now based on
a lot of your reactions to that
statement as you know in your idea phase
as a seed in the US companies are able
to get four to ten million dollars
valuation the insanity and borderline
fraud that is going on with icos in the
crypto world I mean this is just a
completely non practical ten years of
global economic growth broken landscape
that absolutely has nothing grounded in
practicality I want to remind everybody
in this room when you're building a
startup you're building a business not a
financial arbitrage machine that has to
hit web economic data points to raise
your next round based on users and all
this other horseshit that VC propaganda
has pumped into the system for their
selfish points of view on what they're
doing and by the way I'm a capitalist
like I love all the VCS I am a VC but I
need the founders and startups in here
to understand their business model
because their advice is predicated on
what they need to be doing for
themselves and their shareholders
not for what they should be doing for
you and more importantly the VC
landscape is littered with at its best
husbands and people that have never done
it and the advice lacks the practicality
of the current landscape and so I I hope
everybody heard me very clearly and when
you reread the transcript I have no
problem with people that are deploying
capital as somebody who's on the other
end of emails like the one I got the
other day when somebody who lost
$300,000 of my hard-earned money said it
was no big deal and he was glad that he
learned and I was like that's nice that
you learned [ __ ] but you lost my
money there are both sides of this
ecosystem that are at fault
both founders and VC's right now lack
practicality in a 20-18 world because
the world is too flush with money and
many of you in here are not actually
building businesses you're building a
house of cards that falls the second
there's any economic slowdown or any
algorithm change by one of the platforms
that you're actually building your
company on top of so again and and very
much my hope this morning where the QA
goes as I try to navigate through Yuans
hair.i I hope that what I can put in the
ground is what has serviced me super
well for the last twenty years and will
for the next thirty years which is are
you grounded in practicality do you
actually live and navigate in the year
that you actually live in are you
factoring in enormous economic
prosperity for a decade and when does
that go away
are you factoring in that you're
building your business on top of
somebody else one of my favorite things
that's going on right now back to
building on top of somebody else is how
many people complain how many people six
or twelve months ago started seeing
their friends or startups complain about
Instagram or Facebooks algorithm change
and I would sit there and I would laugh
as people would cry
about this and I would remind them and I
remind you Helsinki this morning those
platforms are free the platforms are
free all the people that are complaining
that they're not getting as many likes
or engagement or the organic reach went
down need to be reminded that you built
your content on these platforms you
built something on the free attention
that these platforms add you selfishly
took that attention for your interest
and then when it started to decline at
the cost of free you got [ __ ] pissed
that makes no sense practically and so
if you're building your business on top
of another company and you're getting
the benefits of it for free take the
goods while the goods are being given
take that data and then make it your own
build your first party ecosystem around
that and then move on your merry way but
definitely don't be at the reliance of
the platform there are many people here
who will continue to navigate off that
free and then be caught and I just AM
struggling and actually that's a good
way to set this up I'm struggling with
the lack of practicality and naivete in
our ecosystem about what's gonna happen
my favorite day recently in the tech
world was when Amazon in America bought
Whole Foods a large food retailer
everybody was stunned like shocked like
all the big CPG companies the Coca
Cola's the Pepsi's the Quakers the
Campbell soups of the world all of a
sudden who were pooh-poohing Amazon for
only representing one percent of their
business now had a new problem because
they owned one of the most important
retailers and I read all the comments
and I read all my emails and I just
watched the world in that world react to
it and I was taken aback by people's
naivete as if we don't understand what's
happening here guys do you understand
that Apple can
by every company that you think is
awesome multiple times over I don't
think people understand what the
alibaba's and the $0.10 and the Amazons
and the apples and the googles and the
Facebook's are about to do they're gonna
buy the full stack when when you wake up
and you see that you know Alibaba bought
Tesco or when Facebook buys Target like
this is where it's going and so again
the framework that I'm trying to create
this morning is one very simple thing
which is this has just started
the Internet's the middleman the
Internet's the middleman and there's
seven to ten companies in the world
globally who've been able to build the
layer directly on top of the Internet
they've won our jobs all here is to be
the next layer after that the people in
this room that understand how to
navigate Amazon and Apple and Google and
$0.10 and Facebook best in a world where
you extract the value from it before it
extracts the value from you will be the
individuals that are most successful and
so the reason I'm building this
framework is knowing that I'm gonna have
a lot of time with QA and when we get to
Q&A please ask me any basic very
needle-in-a-haystack question that's
what I'm here for
but what I'm trying to do this morning
is get everybody's mindset into what's
actually happening here and what's
actually happening here is that uber and
Amazon and Airbnb they're the preview
they're not the anomaly every industry
that every one of us are in is on call
and the internet is lurking and somebody
and something is going to attack where
we're doing our thing and so that leads
me to the place that matters to me the
most in a world where you're like okay
if you believe what I'm saying
if it makes sense to you the question
becomes now what and then now what of
all of this gets to a very interesting
place which is the following
the number one thing that I would
implore everybody to be thinking about
in this room is your brand the reason
your brand matters so much is it's the
most ownable asset it's also the thing
that will protect you the most over the
next twenty thirty years
let me explain one of my biggest thesis
is at this point right now is that voice
is going to be a fundamentally
game-changing technology for all of us
because we all value time over almost
everything else besides our health
everybody here that now takes out their
phone to do many actions will be doing
it directly from their lips to not a
device like an Alexa pod or things of
that nature but to the integration of
speakers in our everyday life for
example all of you that are wearing
clothes today whether it's a tie or a
shirt it's a very highly likely world
where there will be voice-activated
capabilities in those products or in
your ear or your ear pods or wherever it
may go the friction between you saying
something like there's information you
want or a transaction that you want to
create and the ability for that to
happen is going to be almost zero when
that happens there are many things that
are in trouble first of all at firmers
the reason Google has to win this game
is that Google text search isn't deep
[ __ ] the days of you going to your phone
and typing in a search query a decade
from today are going to be over because
it's gonna take you longer than saying
who was the president in 1967 how many
miles before this is my restaurant open
and I'm sure how many of you saw the
Google assistant demo a couple weeks ago
just raise your hands some crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that's today's technology where
do you think that's going so in a world
of voice that I think is going to eat up
buying decisions are you in a place
where when I say Alexa get me a black
car
or Alexa get me an uber that becomes a
very interesting conversation in a world
where we know Kleenex or Xerox or things
of that nature
they've won this game if you tell Alexa
to send you a pair of jeans Amazon is
gonna have the leverage they're either
gonna send you a private label or
they're gonna make a brand pay through
the nose to be the default jeans to all
of our language the number one thing
that will protect your business over the
next decade is building a brand around
your business building a brand that
transcends all the advancements that
we're about to make in technology that
eliminate friction from the
decision-making process we've gone from
the Yellow Pages or any directory that
you had in this country to Google and
next it's gonna play out in voice and I
wouldn't bet against Amazon and when you
think about Amazon as a retailer that
becomes unbelievably dangerous one could
be sitting here and say fine Gary but
I'm not in the consumer space I'm in the
b2b space which is great but I promise
you the way that many will pick their
lawyer pick their contractor their IT
developer will be the same way they do
today which is through utility based
search or word of mouth both which will
play out in voice both that will require
everybody here to create brand and so
where am I going with this here's where
I'm going there are way too many people
in this room that are over reliant on
math they were in the sales business not
the marketing business the way they
succeed is through the digital age of
transactions and they look at things
like CAC and LTV and quant based metrics
and that's great and incredible to get
you to a point but the point of my
existence in the marketing landscape and
where I see all the opportunity going
forward has far more to do about brand
there are very few people here that are
thinking about how to spend five to
twenty five thousand dollars to make a
video that's two to three minutes long
that tells the story emotionally about
what they're doing and then
thinking about how to distribute that
content in a Facebook and Instagram
world for another twenty thousand
dollars the amount of people here who
are willing to roll the dice on fifty
thousand dollars on a video on Facebook
to make their world work is quite low
it's high risk it's not as measurable
and it's something that most people
aren't investing in at the same token I
personally believe that's exactly what
people need to be investing in right now
cuz at the end of this war which is what
it is don't get confused of what Apple
and Facebook and Google and $0.10 and
Alibaba this war where you're gonna see
more walls put up not sharing data
that's where all the money is this war
what's going to happen is our worlds are
gonna become unbelievably frictionless
and we're gonna be doing things that are
completely predicated on brand the
number one way for you to get ready for
that because I'm not interested in
telling you what's gonna happen in 7 or
9 or 13 years cuz that is totally not
practical the quickest way for you to
understand that world is for YouTube
right now become a practitioner of
Facebook advertising and Instagram
advertising in this market or any market
that you're marketing in outside of
mainland China and Russia you have to
have to become a practitioner of
influencer marketing of Facebook media
spend of creative in these platforms the
outsourcing and relying on others in
social media marketing is the mass
vulnerability of this collective room
being a headline reader versus a
practitioner is the thing that I'm most
worried about in this room do you know
many people in this room have opinions
about Facebook and Twitter and snapchat
and Instagram and their ad product and
their capabilities to move their
business without ever running an ad on
the platform my friends it's almost 2019
like
the days of putting your head in the
ground and hoping this isn't happening
or having a very basic point of view on
these platforms is coming to an end
you've been able to get away with kind
of knowing about the capabilities I do
not believe that we have the luxury of
that and because of that and then we'll
go into Q&A on I see you hovering
because of that for the 30% of people
that raised their hand earlier of being
entrepreneurs or startups because of
that this is the greatest era to be an
entrepreneur startup ever because the
rules are so extreme that the incumbents
people that have been successful don't
have the leverage that they have
historically had because the
infrastructure costs were deployed
against the world that doesn't exist
anymore you have to understand that the
advantages that Bruce and I and others
that have been able to succeed in those
values are not as valuable as they were
if we were no navigating 50 years ago
because the property we owned or the
media that we owned it was more valuable
the speed in which your attention is
moving and to where is remarkable and
the reason you're seeing such incredible
change politically at a geo level and
emotionally and the issues that we're
facing as humans and talking about
whether it's racism or sexism or
nationalism is happening strictly
because of this because as a boy that
was born in the Soviet Union I'm
unbelievably aware of what propaganda
and media do we're all becoming a hell
of a lot more aware of it the fact that
you have fundamental control and
incredibly low cost to do that for your
selfish business ambitions with all good
intentions it's nice to build a business
that's great the fact that you can do it
too and you're not taking full advantage
of it is the greatness of your life
thank you
[Applause]
alright alright so it's time for Q&A
okay
yes and for this theory we're gonna
start a little bit especially we're not
gonna go straight
we're not gonna go straight to audience
we actually have people from I don't
know a future past and we're gonna have
them appear on the screen and they're
gonna ask the question so can we get the
first question please let's see what's
gonna happen
help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my only
hope
excuse me sir I was traveling across the
galaxies to find the one can you help me
yes Danny you got it [ __ ] sorry yes I
can't do it you to bring me back oh
she's good I love it
alright that was quick one do we have
another question and not Star Wars
interruptions
oh hi there my name is Alexy hop Aoki
and I'm here to ask a question Gary so
my question for you is what is the next
thing that marketers will ruin thank you
you're welcome
so I often talk about marketers ruin
everything right you know my career is
trying to figure out where you're
spending your time organically and then
I'm trying to figure out how to
penetrate it and sell [ __ ] you know and
so I think the thing that you know it's
there's nothing that's very
black-and-white to me but if you look at
email the reason we've all protected our
text messages so much is we gave up our
email and marketers ruined it
right I think that the next thing will
clearly be voice but I think what we've
learned from Facebook this is the great
misunderstanding of Facebook's era is
that the algorithm changes because the
only asset Facebook has is your
attention and as soon as they see that
they're putting too much ads or things
that you don't want they start
eliminating it to keep you there I think
that has changed my historic point of
view on marketers ruin everything I
think everybody here is starting to
intuitively understand that through
marketing we need to bring more value
it's less about interrupting and being
selfish and it's more about being
bringing value but to answer it directly
I think the voice space is gonna be the
big battleground where we'll get a lot
of value and then marketers will come in
and try to figure out how to get our
attention and buy [ __ ] it's like you're
gonna ask oh ask Alexa or something
first gonna give you an ad before he
gives you the answer I don't know if I
don't think Amazon's gonna give us an ad
I don't think when Bruce says hey I want
some toilet paper or toothpastes that
Amazon's right move is saying Bruce you
know you should try the new crest
nobody's gonna want that I think where
Amazon has unbelievable leverage is when
he says I want three tubes of toothpaste
they're gonna just send whatever the
[ __ ] they want because I think the thing
that you'll be stunned by is there's
very few things that you actually very
much care about to stay on the same
brand and everybody's different somebody
in the audience here mate
we use this one shampoo others won't
I missed a pair yeah so I can't believe
that I bought three pairs of jeans on
Amazon without saying the brand I
thought I cared about the brands of
jeans that I wore but in the moment as
my behaviors changing I was taught by
myself that it's not a category where I
care versus cereal I would never say to
Google Google sent me some cereal I'm
gonna say semi [ __ ] Captain Crunch so
I think I think it's gonna be
interesting to see where it goes but I
don't think it's gonna be an ad I think
it's gonna be the leverage of sending
whatever you want that blue bar at the
top of Google is not gonna be a
suggestion anymore it's where you're
gonna go and as you can imagine that's
gonna be very expensive all right thank
you
next question please hi Gary nice to
meet you my name is Benoit I'm from
France I live here and work here in
Finland for project called Moscow a club
for foodie very glad to meet you I have
a question for you Gary I was wondering
do you believe in teleportation No
I mean the reality is is that I like to
talk about [ __ ] that I know I have no
knowledge or expertise and teleportation
so the answer is no my friend but I like
your shirt okay thank you for the UH
thought wow okay okay bye bye Benoit are
you somewhere here Oh over here you wore
the same shirt love that one more here
we go into audience we have a couple
more okay okay I got a 15 my name is
Matt I'm Aneta I'm not familiar letting
up here in the Nordics from the states
and I have a question for you so what
are the three main points you look for
in a project before you'll devote time
and money into it so this has been an
interesting transition thanks for the
question my biggest mr. early on I
wasn't an investor I invest in those
three very successful companies then I
started getting high on my own supply
and thought I was special because of
those three bets and I became an
investor in hindsight the very obvious
mistake I made is I've had a good
entrepreneurial career I'm an operator
I'm probably even more a CEO than I am a
CEO if you really look under the hood of
how I navigate so the biggest mistake
that I made was I would look at a
business and I believed in the thesis
and I would invest in it because I knew
what I would do but what I didn't take
into account was that the entrepreneur
or the CEO that she or he wasn't capable
of doing what I would do so in today's
world and I invest very rarely because I
think everything's overvalued I'm just
kind of waiting for the next cycle but
once in a while Robin Shapiro walked
into my office she blew me away with her
concept on cricket protein right so I
did some homework on it she was
unbelievably passionate I believed in
the thesis that cricket as a protein as
a food source has a lot of upside then I
spent a lot of time asking myself do I
believe
she was in it for the long haul and
could she move the company into a
totally different space if it didn't
work out I am now at the point to answer
the question directly 51 percent of my
energy is based on do I believe in her
or him to be able to win the jockey 49
percent on the horse and away I go I
have to fall in love with the person I'd
prefer at this point to mitigate my risk
so I'd love to invest in somebody who
hasn't done it before so I can look
under the hood of how they did it and
then I of course have to believe in the
thesis like you know no question I can
already feel and you could see from the
talk this morning that the apps that are
gonna be built on top of a lexan Google
home is gonna be a place where I do a
lot of investing and so the jockey and
the horse only those two variables okay
I'm not worried about could Google copy
this or Facebook beat this competition
doesn't factor in at all I definitely
don't want to see your [ __ ] math
metrics of in three years we'll be doing
28 million it's straight black magic
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
sorry I mean just like fish like
business school dynamics in a 30 page
deck based on the reality of business is
like [ __ ] outer space like
teleportation so the jockey and the
horse okay good
Oh Matt still there all right hi Gary
OOP hi Arctic 15 name's Matthew Minetta
I'm an entrepreneur living up here in
the Nordics I know Matt you already
asked your question I was off the stage
next one please
what are the three important technology
I get in a project before you'll devote
time and money into it Matthew so what I
look for is the jack just kidding
can we go into the audience I guess you
have like one or two more good good ones
coming okay yep
hello Gary I am Romain from Estonia but
I lived all over the world and I have a
question for you
is there any business area that you
would never invest in - yeah I mean I'm
I don't think it's a good idea Eric I'm
not you know this is where it's a little
tough I don't know if he means
geographically or in genres of business
on right genres yeah yeah um yeah I mean
I don't invest in things that I think
were passed by so I would never invest
in search engines that are print and you
know written based based on what I just
said I don't think it's a good idea to
invest in retail companies that have too
much of their capital tied up in their
locations in a world where ecommerce is
no question generating disruption I mean
the actual answer to this question as
I've gone through my mind is actually a
ton of [ __ ] I think in a world that
we're living in right now where
technology's sweeping our lives it makes
so many areas vulnerable so to me I
probably spend a lot of time eliminating
things and I think there's probably
there's probably way way way more things
I wouldn't invest in anymore I mean I
wouldn't invest in a social network now
it's just so hard to penetrate in a
world where Facebook and the incumbents
I think we all saw what happen with
snapchat enormous growth in essence
ended up being a feature and and now has
to innovate to succeed so my answer is
most things I wouldn't invest in because
I think they're getting disrupted too
aggressively
okay thank you thank you Romain thank
you Gary that was a good answer
bye made a guest room
oh there we go oh hello how's everybody
doing I was reading this amazing book by
you-know-who and I had one question for
you guys actually this one goes to Yong
Yong how's your hair it's really awesome
[Laughter]
nice thank you I think you have one more
or less from the future or deposit hi
Gary my name is Jonathan her Sean and
this blur that you see across my face is
actually deliberate there's no technical
problem here it's just that I'm kind of
famous for the fact that there are no
pictures of me on the Internet and I
would very much like to keep it that way
that's cool so my question for you is
this we're both from Silicon Valley and
we're both here in the Nordics and I've
been involved in public relations for 20
years in the tech scene and I've been
working with a lot of different Nordic
companies over the years and I'm
actually very surprised that more people
in Silicon Valley don't know about the
Nordic tech evolution and the fact that
we actually have great technology up
here so my question to you is this why
do you think more people in Silicon
Valley don't invest in Nordic companies
and how can that be changed thank you my
friend
I think America has an enormous America
bias
I think Silicon Valley entrepreneurs
live in a bubble America is unbelievably
not global it's quite in Soleri
and I think that there's friction in
location and cultures that they don't
think they need to deal with because
there's an abundance of opportunity
within the US in the same way that I
think you'll watch over the next hundred
years China do very much the same the
markets so big there's no reason to
address other markets and so I think
that's the reason and that's why I
really get upset about the VC pedestal
Silicon Valley thing because there's so
many great entrepreneurs here
who
biggest dream is to get funded in
Silicon Valley and win that game where I
feel like that's pandering to something
that is not as practical as all the
opportunity there is to actually just
build a viable business in your market
or your region so to answer the question
my friend I just think it's a u.s. bias
and the u.s. Silicon Valley investment
ecosystem has more than enough
opportunities within it where they can
fly to Chicago in New York or drive down
the street versus having their company
seven hours away okay Jonathan's
actually right here
hey that's a great answer thank you very
much for your time
very appreciated all right that wraps up
our Halle chrome stuff so now does
anybody here have any question to Gary
let's do it all right let's do it
hello how are you good I've been
listening to your podcast for the last
couple of years so huge fan thank you my
name is Taylor I'm from a company called
value er value where AI we connect
startups with corporations my question
is kind of twofold so you've talked
about these unicorns that are looking
into buying up these other larger
companies and other markets and base yes
unilateral yes takeover yes how do you
encourage fortune 500 companies to start
figuring out they need to start shelling
out money now to not be left behind the
problem is I'd yell at them every day
they don't want to do the capital
expenditure because it hurts them in a
90 day window on Wall Street and they
are actually very aware that often their
culture is not a good body for the organ
on the outside that they bring in so I
think you know when everybody wakes up
in three years and realizes that
Unilever paid a billion dollars four
dollars shave club and it failed it's
gonna make Pepsi and Procter and Gamble
and Kellogg's nervous on the flip side
you know just back to your question just
so you know Fortune 500's right now are
unbelievably aggressive on the M&A front
- there's so much underlining M&A going
on right now like they've been commenced
like the way you asked your quest
it's happening you're gonna see an
enormous amount of ma right now from the
haves and have-nots and digital world
the problem is 95% are gonna fail
because what they do you have to
understand you have to follow the money
in the same way that I was like ranting
a little bit about VC's that's Wall
Street you've got the biggest companies
in the world doing everything in their
power to make profit in every 90 days
because the CEO she and his bonus and
stock equity is tied to it nobody's
building businesses
everybody's pandering to [ __ ] numbers
got it
yeah second part how do you tell the
startups hey don't worry about getting
absorbed this is good for you as opposed
to hey I don't want to do business with
you know the big man on the block or
something that's a good question I mean
I think too many startups that's ego and
audacity right startups think they have
this clever IP that if they do a deal
with Dell or Pepsi I usually remind
startups that they're not as good as
they think they are I love when startups
tell me like Garrity you don't get it we
developed something that [ __ ]
Facebook doesn't get and I think a step
back I'm like real quick just let me
understand this right you and two
developers over the last nine months
created some technology that Facebook
and Google and Apple don't get get the
[ __ ] out of here and so I think that
there is way too much ego in the startup
community around this special IP they
have and they're they're not doing it
out of feet they it looks like they're
doing it at not doing it out of fear
they're not doing it out of ego
thank you Gary without Viktor from
Slovakia
how are you Victor I'm great how are you
very good nice first of all thank thank
for our content inspiring our community
in Slovakia so the question is imagine
you are no name you are just starting
would you rather focus on one project or
you try to be involved on to free at the
same time thank you the answer brother
is both will work right I mean the
reality is is there's no right answer
depends on the skill in here for me in
my youth I focused on one project there
was a family business they worked I
learned a lot of things great but as you
probably know consuming my content some
of the biggest things I'm pushing right
now is be very aggressive in your 20s
and try a lot of things some people are
naturally self-aware and have a very
clear vision others are still trying to
figure it out I think the answer for
them if I can bring value to the most
people here is if you have 100%
conviction and you know exactly what
you're passionate about and what you're
good about well then go but if you have
any doubt early on this is where you
could take the most risk right what most
humans do is start making money and then
start creating debt or overhead that MIT
puts them into a box the beauty the
beauty of being in your 20s is you don't
have money or stuff often and so that
allows you the freedom to try [ __ ] and
during an era like this trying [ __ ]
around AI or AR or crypto blockchain is
a great thing because you may stumble on
your passion and what you're good at
so both can work it comes down to the
individual and let me give you one other
piece of advice if you're saying
yourself [ __ ] then what do I do
you're never gonna know the alternative
if you go in all in on a project you're
never gonna be able to figure out if you
tried other things so this is more about
being optimistic or pessimistic as a
human being you know if in ten years if
you didn't try something else
even if you're successful and you're a
pessimist you're gonna make up in your
own mind that if you did something else
it would have been better so I think
this is about making it
vision and not dwelling or pondering on
what if because what ifs crippled people
all right we have time for one more and
then we have one more thing after that
some sigh here here come near near the
stage hi Gary
great to have you here thank you it's
real I'm a huge fan thank you you
actually the voice of my bedside stories
so thanks about the podcast I've been
listening for a couple of years and we
actually started with my team a podcast
to start with to learn and build a
community so now we have about three
hundred thousand listeners Wow
congratulations thank you in Finland on
you it's quite nice not more than me but
that's a lot so now we're building what
we learned is that we started with on a
female and sexuality and talking about
sex in a humorous way and directly and
now we learn that we also need to
include the guys understood we are
building out and what before you go any
further why have you learned you need to
include the guys because you want a
bigger audience or because you feel like
there's things that are missing well to
make the everyday life of people in
relationships better right we need to
understand okay go ahead so um we want
to build this and we are building this
digital foreplay with an A or twist
called more and better it's for couples
relationship and and now we have this
audience here in the podcast and how do
we get it to track very easily you throw
right hooks like you basically I mean
you listen to my podcast right yeah as
you know when I have things I care about
whether it's my sneaker my book my voice
con I will read my own ads in the
beginning of my podcast before I go into
my podcast I think the most interesting
thing that people struggle with when
they figured out how to build an
audience which is to bring value is to
then get the gear to ask that audience
for something I would have you and
whoever else is part of the show or
whoever is in the show to
ads like before you start the podcast
you say hey we've got our new app and
before you listen to the rest of this
podcast it would mean the world to us if
you go download the app and then you
just keep on [ __ ] asking thank you
we have run run out of times for the
questions partner but when we have a
really quick one startup pitch to you
okay so Samsa from gyaku come on states
or pits from the microphone let's do
this come on watch out for yarns here
yeah hey Gary thanks for the how are you
good good yeah I appreciate you being
very vocal about the voice coming up and
I share the passion
I'm building a voice community and
basically what I'm thinking here is that
there's two things in the voice
there's the complexities of finding good
stuff to listen so yes you know that's
all over the place then there's the
length of the content yes makes it
difficult to consume on the go and then
there's the sort of one directionality
of it there's no sort of conversational
dialogue so that's what we are trying to
solve build the dialogue between people
we call the mini cast so what I'm
wondering is that do you see that
there's space for bi-directional
conversational service around the voice
and if so shall we partner or shall we
compete I you know I think that's it so
I want to let's keep going here because
I want to make sure I fully understand
you want to build a platform that allows
yon and I to communicate through voice
devices basically it's a you can think
of it as an Instagram of voice or
Twitter of voice you can do your mini
cast which is a short voice commentary
on your phone others can reply and come
by and a I helps to build sort of
conversation trends my belief is that
that's gonna be more friction than you
realize meaning there's a reason that we
text each other and don't send each
other voice memos back and forth because
it's fast
or to text I think when we communicate
with an AI voice device that replies in
real-time that's more of a utility or
could be entertainment I think when it
comes to peer-to-peer communication text
is faster than voice which is why we're
doing less phone calls and why we don't
do voice memos so if you asked me that
wouldn't be the place that I would first
go to because if you think of oxr if you
think of other things there's been other
things you can layer AI on top of it I'm
not so sold that that's the consumer
behavior that is obvious to me yet now
what may happen is as we get sucked into
engaging with voice devices in an
everyday life it may we may migrate
because we use it this way with a device
to the way we talk with each other to
more voice but I feel like that is a
secondary behavior built on the back of
us interacting with AI devices not the
primary thing that we're gonna start
with which would then make me believe
that what you're positioning is seven to
ten years away if it even happens more
so than the thing that I would believe
happens next one man's point of view
very quick follow-up yes so my point is
that when we do broadcast today yes they
are Studio productions what I claim is
tick is ready that you can do that from
your phone this weekend have you seen
Ankur sure so I think they're the ones
who are claiming or at least or early in
the US market to be doing that and it's
I'm watching it very careful I'm not an
investor advisor I know them but not
really all that well but I like them I
do think there's something to that I I
see it a lot of my fans when I bring it
up start their podcasts on this and I do
think there's a space for that for sure
understood all right thank you so much
all right everybody let's take a quick
group selfie to wrap this thing up can
you
little bit warm it up and get up and
cheer for us yes oh [ __ ]
how's the heck alright thank you
Helsinki thank you for having me thank
you if you want Gary to ever come back
to Helsinki clap a little bit louder
please
[Applause]
[Music]
you